Hi, I'm Dr. McInerno.
I'm an emergency medicine
physician, and most of you
know me from the OMM lab.
Today, we're going
to talk about
anaphylaxis and
allergic reactions.
This is near and dear to
my heart as an emergency
medicine physician who has
taken care of many patients
with both anaphylaxis
and allergic reactions.
So, the objectives for
today are to discuss the
four hypersensitivity
reactions, with the main
emphasis being on type 1
hypersensitivity reactions,
because our allergies
and our anaphylactic
reactions are type 1
hypersensitivity reactions.
We're going to
identify the clinical
manifestations of
allergies and the
differential diagnosis
of allergic reactions.
We're going to recognize
when a patient is
having an anaphylactic
reaction, and then we're
going to talk about
the treatment of both
anaphylactic and non
-anaphylactic reactions.
so we're going to talk
about some definitions the
reason we're going to
bring these up is because
these terms are going to
be used throughout the
lecture and want to make
sure we all have a basic
understanding of them some
of this may be a little
bit of review so what
is an antigen an antigen
written sometimes as ag
for shorthand is a foreign
or self molecule that
triggers an immune response
What do I mean
when I say foreign?
Peanut butter is an
example of an antigen to
some people who are
allergic to peanut butter.
It's foreign. It does not
live in our cells. It does
not live in our body. I
don't have peanut butter
just sloughing around in
my blood vessels. So it's
not foreign that we don't
know what it is, but it's
foreign to our body. It
doesn't live in our body.
A self-molecule that can
trigger an immune response
is when we respond to
something that is innate in us.
That's what we think of when we
think of autoimmune diseases.
It is the immune
system responding and
treating the self
as if it was for it.
An antibody,
shorthand AB,
is B cell produced
molecules that are
encoded by genes that
have both heavy and
light chains that
bind to the antigens.
So examples of antibodies,
IgG, IgE,
IgM.
So there is a normal
protective role
of IgE, that antibody,
in host defense.
Because remember,
we're talking about
the immune system.
Our immune system's
function is to
protect the body.
So an allergy is an abnormal
IgE-mediated immune response
to an otherwise harmless
substance, that antigen.
So example again, we bring
out that peanut butter.
Peanut butter sitting on
the shelf in the grocery
store is pretty harmless.
It's a harmless substance.
But when we have an
abnormal response
to that, that's when
we get an allergy.
And what does anaphylaxis
mean? It is the antithesis
of prophylaxis. So
you've probably heard of
the term prophylaxis,
meaning toward protection.
We're going to protect
against something.
We're going to get a
vaccine prophylactically.
so we don't catch COVID
or tetanus. So the
antithesis of prophylaxis
is anaphylaxis.
And complement. Now you
can probably write a whole
chapter in a book or
if not a whole book on
complement. We are definitely
not going to do that.
We're going to just talk
about complement in terms
of knowing that they
are plasma proteins that
play a role in innate
immunity and inflammation.
All right. So we're
going to move on to our
hypersensitivity reactions.
Now, you guys know
that I am a physician. I
am not an immunologist.
And you might say, well,
why are we going to
discuss the hypersensitivity
reactions, which are
basic science here in
this clinical lecture?
Because they're very
important. It puts the
whole picture together.
You really can't talk
about allergies and
anaphylaxis without even
mentioning the
hypersensitivity reactions.
And another important
reason, the boards, the
Comlocks, the USMLE, they
love hypersensitivity
reactions. So it's very
important to know about them.
Hypersensitivity reactions,
there are four types, type
1, type 2, type 3, and type
4. I am actually going to
talk about them in the order
of type 2 through 4, and
then 1. And the reason I'm
going to go in that order
is because the allergies and
the anaphylaxis fall into
type 1 hypersensitivity
reactions. And this is a
clinical lecture, and that's
the bulk of it. So we're going
to do the biomedical part
with the hypersensitivity
reactions and then focus on
that type 1 hypersensitivity
reaction and go straight
into the clinical realm.
So these hypersensitivity
reactions are immunological
responses that affect
the host adversely.
So very busy slide, and I
totally understand that.
But people organize
material differently. And if
you're a person who likes
tables, I think this is a good
table that shows the
immunological reactions that
occur in the different
hypersensitivity reactions.
So you can compare type 1
to type 3, type 2 to type
4, and it kind of puts it
all together on one slide.
What we're going to
do is we're going
to take them step by
step, and we're going
to talk a little
bit about each one.
But you have the
table for review or
if you just want
it all on one page.
So as I said, we're
going to start with
the type 2
hypersensitivity reaction,
also known as the
cytotoxic reaction.
So we have antigens on
cell surfaces. They attract
the antibody, IgG and
IgM in this case, and
they promote cell lysis
via the complement system.
And a big example of a
type 2 hypersensitivity
cytotoxic reaction is
a transfusion reaction.
And what we're
talking about in this
transfusion reaction is
our ABO incompatibility
transfusion reactions,
the really bad ones.
And someone gets the
wrong blood type.
So we're going to take a
look here at this picture.
We have a red blood
cell. And the red blood
cell has antigens on
its cell membrane.
and you have IgG antibody
that binds to the antigen.
When you get that antibody
and antigen binding,
it activates complement,
these plasma proteins,
and then it forms a
membrane attack complex
or an antibody-dependent
cellular cytotoxicity.
this membrane attack
complex then composes the
cell, lices the cell. Sorry,
I shouldn't say composes.
It lices the cell. It's
composed of complement
and it lices the cell. And
that causes cell death.
So you have antigen,
antibody bind,
activate complement.
You form this membrane
attack. Think of
the word attack,
complex, because it's
attacking the red blood
cells and lysosing
the red blood cells.
Type 3 hypersensitivity
reactions. Type 3 hypersensitivity
reactions are the immune
complex reactions.
So in this case, the antigen
is freely circulating.
It is not on a cell wall.
It's freely circulating.
It binds to antibody. It
gets deposited in blood
vessel walls, and it causes
an inflammatory reaction.
An example is serum sickness.
So again, we take
a look here. We
have antigen. We have antibody.
The antigen and antibody
form these complexes. But
as you can see the antigen
here, it is multivalent.
So it means it can bind
more than one antibody. You
have antigen, antibody. Two
antibodies on this antigen.
This antigen has three
antibodies on it. This
whole thing forms this immune
complex. And now the immune
complex gets deposited
on the blood vessel wall.
That immune complex
then activates
complement. And the
C5A component of
complement attracts
our neutrophils.
So now the neutrophils are
attracted to the
blood vessel wall.
They release enzymes.
Those neutrophils release
enzymes that destroy the
endothelium in the blood
vessel wall. And the red
blood vessels escape.
This is how you get
an immune complex
type 3 hypersensitivity
reaction.
And now we're going
to go on and talk
about the type 4
hypersensitivity
reactions, the cell
-mediated reactions.
So all the other
hypersensitivity reactions have
to do with antibody
-mediated. But type 4 is
cell-mediated. It is T
cell-mediated. It is also
known as the delayed
hypersensitivity reaction.
So we said it still
made it the previously
sensitized T1 helper cells.
And then you have cells
recognizing an antigen.
They become the antigen
presenting cell and they
release cytokines to
recruit more T1 helper
cells and mononuclear cells.
And you have an
inflammatory reaction. And
what is an example of a
type 4 hypersensitivity
reaction would be your
contact dermatitis.
So again, we're going to
take a look at the picture.
So in this picture,
what do I have here?
I have Pac-Man. Pac
-Man is the macrophage.
So Pac-Man, our macrophage,
gets a hold of this antigen,
ingests that antigen,
and becomes the antigen
-presenting cell. It
forms this little epitope
that presents on the
cell when you have an
antigen-presenting
cell. You also have the
macrophage releasing
these interleukins, these
cytokines, that then
attract our helper T cells.
Our helper T cells then release
interferin, and interferin
activate macrophages
and recruit more
helper T-cells.
So it becomes a cyclic
inflammatory reaction cycle.
And finally, I go to our
type 1 hypersensitivities,
because remember,
this is a clinical
lecture on allergies and
anaphylaxis, which belong
into the type 1
hypersensitivity reaction.
Type 1 hypersensitivity
reactions have
two phases. There is
the immediate phase,
kind of what we think
of when we kind of
first hear the word
allergy and anaphylaxis.
In the immediate hypersensitivity
reaction, we have
antigens that cross
-link preformed IgE on
presensitized mast cells. And
that leads to degranulation
and leads to the release
of preformed histamine,
tryptase, and leukotrienes.
So let's take a look
at this picture. You have
right here, this mast
cell. And this mast cell
has these IgEs on it.
And then the antigen
comes. And the antigen
binds to, as you can
see here, this antigen
is binding to this IgE
and this IgE, which
is causing crosslinks
of preformed IgE.
What happens then
is that mast cell
degranulates. And when
it degranulates, it
releases histamine,
tryptase, leukotrienes.
Now you have a
delayed or late hours
type 1 hypersensitivity
reaction.
In this case, you have newly
synthesized leukotrienes.
They attract
inflammatory cells,
eosinophils.
You will hear patients,
you know, IAM doctors
talking about their
patients having high
eosinophil counts when
they have allergies.
So this is the reason
here, because these newly
synthesized leukotrienes
are attracting our
inflammatory cells,
our eosinophils, which
of course is going to
raise our eosinophil
count when we have a lot
of allergic reactions.
And that causes inflammation
and tissue damage,
which we see with erythema,
edema, and duration.
So that was kind of,
you know, the last two
slides were kind of the
basics that we did with
the, all the other
hypersensitivity reactions.
Now what I'm going to do
is take this, the type
one, which is our allergic
reaction, and take it
kind of into a step-by
-step form so that we know
exactly a little bit more
details, because this is
the one that's important
for allergic reactions.
So a type one hypersensitivity
reaction, you get
exposed to an allergen,
you get stung by a bee,
And IgE is produced.
And that IgE binds
to the surface
of mast cells and basophils.
So going back to our picture,
you get stung by a bee.
You form this IgE.
And it goes on to the
mast cell. And we stop
at this picture here.
so meaning you get
exposed to the B you you
produce IgE the IgE
binds to the mass non
-basal but you don't
have a systemic reaction
because we haven't hit
step two and step three
now it's summer it's
August you're always
outside and you get a
second exposure you get sung
by a B again now the
allergen binds to the
cell associated IgE that
you formed last time
Now we get that cross
-linking of two IgE
-FC receptor molecules
on the mast cells.
That causes signal
transduction in
the mast cells
and the basophils.
Mediator gets secreted.
Histamine gets
secreted. Now we get
histamine effects
on end organs like
blood vessels,
bronchial smooth
muscles, and we get
the response of an
allergic reaction.
So if we go back to our
picture, now when we get
exposed to that bee
that second time, we're
starting at picture number
two and leading to picture
number three, and we're
getting our reaction.
So the dive in the
late phase is about
six hours after
exposure to the bee.
You get mediators,
leukotrienes that are
newly synthesized after
the cell degraniates.
And you get an influx
of those inflammatory
cells, your neutrophils
and your eosinophils.
And you get a response.
So what is the
biphasic reaction?
You'll hear clinicians
say, we want to
try to prevent the
biphasic reaction.
Bi means two, right? So
it's a reaction meeting
anaphylactic criteria within
48 hours of a previous
reaction without re
-exposure to the antigen.
So basically, the biphasic
reaction is you get the
early phase and you get the
late phase. You get both.
You can have an early
phase alone, you
can have a late phase
alone, or you can
have a biphasic and
allergic reactions.
So let's get a little more
clinical. How do
we get exposed?
Well, the primary exposure
is through the respiratory
system, the GI system, or
the dermatological system,
the skin. So I either
inhale it, I breathe in
pollen, I eat it. I eat some
fish that I shouldn't eat.
Or I get it absorbed through
my skin. I put on a lotion.
And what cells live in
the skin, the mucous
membranes, and the
connective tissues?
Massive.
Now, some people also
just have a pre-genetic
predisposition to allergies.
And why? The answer
why? Well, you can
study that in genetics.
So what are the common
triggers? Because remember in
this, what's important
when you're seeing these
patients is history. They've
got to get a good history.
So foods, medications,
insect bites,
immunotherapy injections,
those are common triggers.
So you want to sit down
with your patient and
try to figure out what
might have caused this.
The symptoms. What
I've done here is
I've put the different
systems and then
what symptoms go
with each system.
So when we think about the
skin and the patient is
presenting with an allergic
reaction, they're going
to have flushing. They're
going to have puritis,
which is itching. They're
going to have urticaria,
hives. Great example here
in the picture of this
kid who you could see
faces, little cheeks are a
little swollen, and there's
hives all over the face.
Respiratory system.
We're going to get
rhinitis, that runny
nose. We're going to
get stridor. We're
going to get wheezing.
Our gastrointestinal system.
Nausea, vomiting, diarrhea
is going to be in effect.
Our ENT system. This
is really important.
We get uvular edema,
tongue swelling,
oral pharyngeal edema.
And why do I say that
one's really important?
Because those are the
ones you really can't
miss because that's bad.
So in the era of COVID, you
need your patient to take
down their mask and you
need to look inside their
mouth because you need to know
if they really have tongue
swelling or uvular edema
or oral pharyngeal edema.
Neurological system. Patients
get headaches.
They get seizures.
And the cardiovascular
system. They get chest pain.
They have hypotension.
So the differential
diagnosis for allergic
reactions is
critically important.
It's critically important
because we don't want
to miss things. We don't
want to get things wrong.
So it's important
on both aspects.
You want to have
anaphylaxis and
allergic reactions
in your differential,
even if maybe you're leaning
more towards its sepsis.
But you also, when you
think it's an allergic
reaction or an anaphylactic
reaction, you also
want to make sure that
you think about the other
causes that it could
be and rule those out.
So it's important to have a
good differential diagnosis.
And so our differential
diagnosis, when
we're kind of thinking,
hey, this is probably
an allergic reaction
or an anaphylactic
reaction, is the life
-threatening causes.
We're going to talk
about those first, and
then we're going to
talk about the non-life
-threatening causes. As
an ER person, I need
to not miss the life
-threatening causes.
But we see a lot of
patients that don't have
life-threatening
causes, and it's also
important to make sure
we get things right.
So make a good differential.
Your life-threatening
causes that you want to
include in your
differential diagnosis are
angioedema, because not
all angioedema is allergic.
Angioedema, acute
coronary syndrome,
arrhythmia, airway
obstructions, foreign bodies,
asthma on other
atopic diseases,
sepsis and septic shock,
pneumothorax, and
scrambroid poisoning.
And then we have our
non-life-threatening
causes. Anxiety, panic attacks,
vasovagal reactions
and syncope,
dermatitis,
gastroenteritis,
chronic urticaria,
mastocytosis, and
liver dysfunction.
I'm going to give you an
example, a real-life example,
where the differential
diagnosis was important.
When I was a resident, we
got a call from EMS. It came
in as alert. The patient
was in septic shock and
code sepsis. Okay. And
everybody's, you know, sepsis,
sepsis, sepsis. And we don't
want to miss sepsis. It's
true because if you treat
sepsis early on, you save
lives. And so the patient
came into the recess bay,
you know, antibiotics
are getting started. IV
fluids are getting started.
Sepsis panel labs are
being drawn, chest x-ray,
urine to change. What
is the cause of sepsis
for this patient. The
patient was probably
about a six-year-old male.
He was alert. He was
oriented, but he was
hypotensive. And he was
complaining of feeling dizzy,
feeling very tired with
a malaise type feeling.
And he knew his blood
pressure was low
because he even had
taken it at home.
He said earlier in
that morning, he
had a headache and
took some naproxen.
He had no
symptoms or complaints
that led to thinking of
anything infectious. He
didn't even have a fever.
I recall my attending, you
know, having us even get
a CT scan to make sure
that he did not have an
intra-abdominal process
that was causing like an
abscess in the GI system
that was causing his sepsis.
Urine was negative. Chest
surgery was negative.
CT was negative.
And talking more and more
with a patient, I discovered
that this patient said
he really only maybe took
naproxen once or twice
before. It was his wife's.
His wife gave it to him
for a headache. It resolved
the headache. But then,
of course, a couple hours
later, he started not
feeling well and, you know,
became hypotensive.
Well, we treated him,
you know, with IV fluids.
We treated him with
pressors to increase
his blood pressure.
He was getting better.
And after everything came
back, that was negative,
we realized that this man
was not in septic shock.
He was in anaphylactic
shock from his naproxen.
The epinephrine, the
IV fluids is what was
helping him, not the
antibiotics that we gave him.
So again, thinking
outside the box, thinking
of what else could
it be. And that's
really important in all
aspects of medicine.
So the diagnosis of the
anaphylaxis, it is very
important to know this
diagnosis of anaphylaxis
because studies were
showing that people
were getting treated so
often when they had mild
anaphylaxis as just a
simple allergic reaction
and were not being
treated for anaphylaxis.
So we started thinking, we
have to have criteria to
figure out when a patient
has anaphylaxis versus
when they have a non
-anaphylactic allergic reaction.
So you can call a patient
anaphylaxis and treat them
for anaphylaxis one of
three ways. When they have
the acute onset of
mucocutaneous symptoms, the
flushing, the pyritus, the
urticaria, the angioedema,
plus one or more
of the following.
Wheezing stridor hypoxia,
the respiratory symptoms,
or the hypotension
or end organ damage.
So that's one way to
diagnose anaphylaxis. So
you've got like your mucoskin
findings and wheezing,
say, or mucoskin
findings and hypotension.
Second way to diagnose
anaphylaxis is two or
more of the following
that occur rapidly after
an exposure to a known
or suspected allergen.
Mucocutaneous involvement,
respiratory symptoms,
hypotension or end organ
hypoperfusion, GI symptoms,
your abdominal pain, your
nausea, your vomiting.
So a patient who has
a salad for lunch and
comes in with wheezing and
nausea potentially can have
anaphylaxis. Now, if we
know they're allergic to
walnuts and there were walnuts
in the salad, we definitely
can diagnose them with
anaphylaxis. I say
potentially because not every
person who has wheezing
and nausea has anaphylaxis.
Again, in this case, they
had a suspected allergen
and they have the wheezing
and nausea. They meet the
criteria for anaphylaxis.
Again, it's always taking
the whole picture into
account, talking to your
patients, history and
physical, putting it together.
And number three, how do
you diagnose anaphylaxis?
Hypotension within
minutes to hours
after exposure to
a known allergen.
And in all honesty, when
we look back and think
about this patient that
I just told you the
story of the naproxen
guy, he actually met the
criteria of anaphylaxis
by number three, except
he didn't know it was
an allergen at the time.
He learned later that it
was an allergen after his
visit with us in the emergency
department and probably
following up with allergy
testing, but hypotension
within minutes, hours after
an exposure to a known
allergen. In that case, we
had to suspect that was the
allergen because it was the
only thing different that
he did. And all the other
differential diagnoses were
getting ruled out as we
were treating this patient.
When we talk about
anaphylaxis, when the patient
meets the criteria for
anaphylaxis, but it
involves hypotension,
they are actually also
considered an anaphylactic
shock. And the only
reason I bring that up is
obviously patients with
shock need to be treated
more aggressively.
So what do you want
to do for your patient
in the picture below
after she ate a kiwi.
So I'm going to give you a
couple minutes to think about
it, or you can turn off
and pause your lecture as
you think about how you're
going to treat this patient,
right? Let's take a
look at this patient.
You can see that half of
her tongue is swollen.
If we look here, half of
I know that you can't
get the rest of the good
exam. She is not real
life in front of you.
So I will tell you that she is
talking in complete sentences.
She tells you her
tongue feels swollen,
but when you examine
her mouth, the
uvula is midline and
it is not swollen.
She also has hives
all over her body.
So what are we going to start
with, with this patient?
Airway protection. We want
to protect the airway.
Airway is critical. We
need an airway to live.
ABCs, right? So we want to
protect her airway. In the
case of this patient, I'm
not going to intubate her
airway. She's talking in
complete sentences. Her tongue
is halfway swollen. I can
still see her airway. She
is still maintaining and
protecting her own airway.
However, these patients get a
warning from me
and I tell them,
I'm going to do everything
I can to treat you
and not intubate you.
But if you're getting
worse before you're
getting bitter, and that
swelling is increasing
instead of decreasing.
Your voice starts
getting muffled.
We can't see your
airway anymore.
We are going to intubate you.
And I tell these patients
this to give them that
warning, number one,
because some patients want
to talk to their family,
want to tell their
family, hey, I'm pretty
sick. I'm in the hospital.
There's a chance I might
get a breathing too.
In addition, we want them
to know, hey, if you have
to these changes, you need
to let us know right away.
And we're going to
watch these patients
closely, closely,
closely for any
changes because we
want to intubate early.
If they're progressing,
we want to intubate before
her tongue is touching
her upper lip and her
lower lip. And there's
no way I'm getting a
laryngoscope blade in that
patient because we want
to try to prevent a a
cricothyroidotomy. So we
want to intubate early.
And in the case where
she's still talking on her
own, she's not completely
swollen. I can still see
her uvula. She's talking
in complete sentences.
I'm letting her know I'm
treating you. You're at high
risk. If you're progressing
and getting worse,
we're intubating you before
things get really bad.
What am I going to
do for this patient?
What am I going
to treat her with?
Epinephrine,
epinephrine, epinephrine.
epinephrine is the gold
standard for anaphylaxis 0.3
to 0.5 milligrams i am in
the thigh why our thigh has
a big quad muscle and we
can put it in and get that
right into the muscle if
you go it in a smaller
muscle there's a chance that
it may not become intramuscular
and you need this in
the muscle as soon as
possible so it can start
working patients may be out and
about and have an allergic
reaction. Patients do carry
EpiPens who are known to
have allergic reactions.
Patients can give the
shot through their pants
and through their clothing.
Now, obviously in the
hospital is a different
story. We can take the
clothing off, but if
you're, you know, in the
middle of Central Park,
you may probably don't
want to take your pants
off and you can give that
epinephrine shot right
through your clothing.
PEDS dosing is obviously
children are smaller.
If they're little, we
use PEDS dosing, which is
going to be less than
the 0.3 to 0.5 milligrams
IM, and it's going to
be 0.01 mg per keg IM.
Again, as I said, epinephrine
is the only evidence
-proven medicine for
anaphylaxis. Why? It increases
peripheral vascular
resistance. It increases
cardiac output. So what
does that do? It increases
blood pressure. It stabilizes
mast cells, so they're
not degranulating, and it
reverses bronchoconstriction
and mucosal edema.
Well, if we reverse
bronchoconstriction, we
can get air into our lungs
and breathe. If we reduce,
reverse mucosal edema,
that airway should remain open
instead of getting
swollen shot.
Unfortunately, some
patients are going to
be refractory to IM
epinephrine. When
they are, and epi
stands for epinephrine.
We want to use IV. The
dosing is different,
but the dosing is
beyond the scope of this
lecture. So don't
worry about it, but you
want to use IV if
they're refractory to IM.
What is important
is decontamination.
Remove the trigger, remove
the allergen. So if you
give a patient epinephrine
and they were stung by
a bee in the hand, but
you never take the singer
out, that venom is that
antigen, and it keeps getting
released. So even
though you keep giving
epinephrine, you keep having
antigen bound to antibody.
Mast cell degranulation.
Histamine gets
released. Allergic
reaction. So we got
to take that insect
singer out and
remove the trigger.
You want to give albuterol
if the patient's wheezing
only? If they're not
wheezing, they don't need
albuterol, but albuterol
will alleviate bronchospasm.
You want to give an IV
crystalloid infusion if they're
hypotensive, because we
give IV fluids when patients
are hypotensive to increase
their blood pressure.
Corticosteroids. The
evidence is low, but
corticosteroids have anti
-inflammatory properties,
and they may help prevent
biphasic reactions.
the antihistamines.
There is no evidence to
support the life-threatening
aspects of anaphylaxis
with the antihistamines.
Benadryl, diphenhydramine,
is not going to save a life,
but it will help with the
cutaneous symptoms. Do
I give it? Yes, I do. I
have a patient who looks
like the lady who ate
the kiwi, her tongue is
swollen, she's scared,
she's itching all over,
maybe feels nauseous, maybe
even wheezing, and she's
itching all over from
hives, let's at least help
her cutaneous symptoms
while we're trying to do
everything else, because
she's going to feel better.
And it's important for
patients to feel better,
as we're also trying
to save their life.
however if you are on the
desert island and you have
only epinephrine that's
okay because people will be
like i don't have benadryl
i don't have diphenhydramine
it's okay you need the
epinephrine the epinephrine
is going to save the
life but do i give in the
hospital the antihistamines
absolutely because i want to
help them feel better as
well and itching people don't
like to itch it's just
not a comfortable feeling.
And people don't
like highs. So we're
going to give them
that to help with their
cutaneous symptoms as
we also treat their
life-threatening
condition, which is the
whatever, the hypotension,
the angioedema
with the epinephrine, the IV
fluids, and everything
else they need.
If your patient is
on a beta blocker,
they may also need
glucagon in order for
the epinephrine to
work and take effect.
So your patient remains
with a blood pressure of 80
over 60 and wheezing. Your
patient has been intubated as
their tongue swelling
increased instead of decreased.
What else can you
do for this patient?
Now, I'm going to tell you
this slide is beyond, beyond
first-year medical school.
I only put this in here
for two reasons. One, to
be thorough and complete.
And I also put this in here
because patients want
to know what's next.
And the more we know what's
next, the more we can
put their minds at ease
and tell them what's next.
But again, this is
beyond first-year medical
school. If you don't
understand anything in this
slide, I'm going to tell
you right now, don't
worry about it at this
point in time. But let's
answer the question.
You're going to give them
additional vasopressors
to increase that blood
pressure. You're going
to call your ECMO team.
There is some data
that methylene blue use
can be helpful in
refractory anaphylaxis.
so what do we do with these
patients we treat them
in the emergency department
for anaphylaxis but
what do we do with them if
they are a low risk patient
and their anaphylaxis
has resolved we have we
will observe them for a
period of time and that period
of time is debatable and
after we observe them
we will discharge them
if they remain stable we
will send them home within
a prescription for an
epinephrine auto-injector,
better known as an EpiPen.
We will consider
sending them home on
steroids or antihistamines
for symptom relief,
and we'll have them
follow up with their ***,
their primary care
physician, or an allergist.
If the patient is a high
-risk patient, they had
mild to moderate
anaphylaxis, meaning they
still have persistent
symptoms or they're at
increased risk of death
from anaphylaxis because
of other comorbid
conditions like congestive
heart failure, chronic
kidney disease, asthma,
a history of severe
allergic reactions, or the
patients on beta blockers.
We will do what we call
a prolonged emergency
department observation
where they'll be placed
in an observation unit or
we'll admit them to the
general medical floor.
and then your severe
anaphylactic patients.
The severe anaphylactic
patients will be placed
in the ICU. They will
be admitted to the ICU.
These are the patients
that are intubated.
These are the
patients who are on IV
epinephrine or received
IV epinephrine.
These are the patients that
need airway monitoring.
So maybe they're not
intubated, but their
tongue is still slightly
swollen and it's not
completely down. And we
need to watch that they
still don't progress
to need an intubation.
So we talked about the really
critical, the anaphylaxis.
Now we're going to
talk about the slightly
easier patient, a patient
who's not as sick,
the non-anaphylactic
allergic reactions.
90% of patients
will have urticaria.
So we want to ask patients
who come in and present
to the emergency department
with urticaria hives
about potential exposures.
I talk to my patients.
I'm like, hey, have you
tried new medications?
Over-the-counter
prescription, herbals.
Have you bought new soaps?
Have you ate new foods? Did
you eat out at a restaurant?
Have you had new exposures,
exposed to something
that you've never been
exposed to before?
Is there a family history
of allergic reactions?
because we're trying
to find out what caused
this allergic reaction
for the patient.
But we also have to remember
that not all rashes are
allergic reactions. Let's
think about an example here.
Peds patient has runny
nose, not feeling well,
cold, and mom gives
cold medication, say
something like a Dimetap
cold medication, and
the kid comes in with a
runny nose and a rash.
We have to remember
that, yes, they could be
allergic to the cold
medication mom gave them,
but they might actually
have what we call a viral
exanthemum, which is
a rash that the virus,
you know, kids who get
viruses get, it's called a
viral exanthemum, and that's
a common rash in children.
So remember, not all rashes
are allergic reactions.
And this is where a
good history and a good
physical will hopefully lead
you to the right answer.
So how do we treat non
-anaphylactic
allergic reactions?
Antihistamines, because
we want to treat
the symptoms, right?
And the antihistamines
are going to help
those symptoms.
So H1 and H2 blockers.
We give both because
studies show that H1 and H2
blockers working in synergy
actually helps with the cutaneous
symptoms better than
just H1 blockers on their
own. So I will tell my patient
in anticipation of their
question, I'm going to give
you some diphenhydramine,
some Benadryl, and some
famotidine and Pepsid to help
with your symptoms and help
your allergic reaction.
I realize that you don't,
you're not complaining of a
stomach ache or any stomach
problems. But the reason
I'm going to give you
the famotidine with the
diphenhydramine is studies have
shown that the two medications
work together better to help
in a large reaction than
just giving the diphenhydramine
or Benadryl alone.
Why do I say that
to my patients?
Because we want our
patients to know that
we listen to them and
we care about them.
And they're not, most
patients know what Pepsid
is. They know what
famotidine is. They see it in
the drugstore. And so we
want them to know that,
hey, we realize that
we're giving you a stomach
medication, but we're not
giving it to you because
of why you might take
Pepsid at home. And it shows
to the patients, hey,
I've thought about this.
I've thought about what
you've told me. I've
listened to what you told
me. This is not a mistake.
We also want to
monitor our patients
for the progression
to anaphylaxis.
And then it's plus or minus
on the corticosteroids. Why?
People like steroids.
Steroids make you feel good.
Steroids will
decrease the itch.
But there is a risk
versus a benefit.
And oftentimes, we
don't think enough
about the risk of
giving steroids.
So I think in a mild to
moderate reaction, we
need to discuss that
risk versus benefit it
and think about it
before we just give the
steroids. Of course, if
it's a severe reaction,
give the clinical steroids.
So what is the risk
of taking steroids?
Well, if you're a
diabetic, it's going to
raise your sugars, which
isn't a good thing.
Steroids make us
hungry. So we eat and
we gain weight when
we're on steroids.
Patients who are prone
to allergic reactions
are often asthma
patients. Asthma patients
already get a lot of
steroids for asthma
exacerbations. And multiple
uses or prolonged uses
of steroids leads to
cataracts in the eye,
leads to osteoporosis. So there
are risks to taking steroids.
So we've covered a lot.
We've talked about allergies
and anaphylactic
reactions being type 1
hypersensitivity reactions.
We talked that epinephrine
is the life-saving
medication in anaphylaxis.
And we want to avoid re
-exposure to a known allergen
when possible. And why do
I say when possible? We
can't live as hermits and
people are allergic to
seasonal allergies. Pollen,
right? The respiratory that
we get in through our
respiratory system, pollen.
Well, unless we're going
to stay at home and never
walk outside, it's kind
of impossible to always
avoid that re-exposure
to that known allergen.
So I say when possible,
if you know you're
allergic to peanut butter,
don't eat peanut butter.
These are the
references for today's
lecture. Here's your
lecture feedback form.
And I want to say
good luck as you study
anaphylaxis and allergic
reactions, as well
as hypersensitivity
reactions. And I wish
you a wonderful day.
Thank you very much.